I heard some disturbing news today and
I'd like to investigate let me explain
I'll do a little uh background first uh
Mr gorley Matt Gourley as you may know
him or just Matt here on the podcast uh
obviously it does a terrific job here at
the show and it's constantly crafting
the the program and making it sound
perfect I think we've covered it yep
we're done no no no no no there's
there's more to cover uh Matt is also
um a bit of a when it comes to
podcasts that's true that he's always
out there I mean I would think being on
Conan O'Brien's friend would be enough I
mean this is so this is a big deal but
no he is uh always off uh working on
hundreds and hundreds of other podcasts
I'm the Wilt Chamberlain of podcasts yes
you are yes you are
um you cannot be sated you you keep
going going and you're always there's
you're always out to conquer another
podcast that you meet in a club late at
night and then bring back to your creepy
1970s
um
house with extra high doorways but
anyway and
I wish I could refute you on anything
yes but
um recently uh Matt was telling us all
in the studio because we hang around
sometimes we're we're friends off Mike
and uh just just pretend the advertisers
like it so they do they want friendship
in order to they just like it they want
people to buy into this as a real family
like the royal family but we all know
deep down what's happening behind the
scenes anyway uh so Matt was telling us
he had a new idea for a podcast called
Mall walking where he walks around a
mall and maybe he has a special guest
with him and just walks around him all
and sees what happened so I think one
interesting idea and again confused that
he needs I mean the man has a child and
a wife uh and he's working with Conan
O'Brien why does he need this but that's
his choice not mine and then yesterday I
was working with Sona you were a me out
with something yeah and uh we were
working on a project together and you
just happened to mention that you were a
guest on Mall walking yeah I was with
Matt Gourley and that things went a
little off the rails and now I turn it
over to you too
well I mean first of all I asked to be
on Mall walking and I was happy happy to
have you we do this show with my friend
Mark mcconville and we went to the mall
which is called the shops at Santa Anita
right and we did what we always do we
walk in with three handheld mics
although we only had two wireless
receivers so I was Tethered to Mark with
a 20-foot cable but wait a minute wait a
minute but not the whole time no because
we had a malfunction so there was a
malfunction so because I would think the
whole idea of doing a podcast called
Mall walking is that you want to be
um not too obtrusive right you want to
sort of fly under the radar and yet you
are lashed to your friend with a cable
yes yeah because of what was the
malfunction uh the wireless receiver on
one of the mics wasn't working right
right okay so and they had a it could
not have been a longer cable I just want
to make sure it's there's no way you
can't notice this this extremely long
cable and they're standing right next to
each other so it's dragging on them wait
you didn't coil it up why didn't you
coil it up oh we did but we gotta you
know we gotta spread out at times where
he's going to the lid store and I want
to check out a Hot Topic you know but
sure you can't you can't have a long
cord between the two of you in a busy
mall we did okay we closed lines some
people all right so so so Sona you're
part of this I am and tell us what's
happening so we started off I had
clothes to return at Old Navy which we
did on Mike we returned clothes on Mike
we returned how am I not listening to
this podcast
this is fantastic
hey we just walk the entire uh second
floor store to store we're talking about
what we see you know and then we're
talking about the candy dispensers I
mean it's really riveting stuff and then
uh and then we get to the end of the
second floor and someone stopped us the
security guard yeah we haven't been to
the first floor yet so we're halfway
through yeah right so you're halfway
through this this show you've returned
some clothes yes and you've you've
looked in lids and uh got us See's Candy
chocolate thing right yeah yeah I made
magic before you can't forget that well
I expensed it to the mall walking yeah
yeah
which is it has an offshore account
I know that this is always for you to
launder cash so so uh you're doing all
that and then
um and then you get to the end of the
second floor of the mall and you're
approached by a security guard and once
you take it here man well he was the
sweetest man yes and he seemed also kind
of reluctant yeah yeah yeah and then uh
Sona kind of took over and actually as
she does yeah and thank God because she
was brilliant and she was really kind
but also very matter of fact basically
said what would your supervisor say to
this let's speak to them so it out comes
his boss who then recognized Sona yeah
oh yeah yeah I he so he he's like you
look familiar and then you know I mean
usually it's because they watch you so I
was like oh I work for Conan O'Brien and
he goes yeah you know I'm Team Coco for
life and so we were like I love this guy
yeah but then we were like so can we
record and he's like no yeah no
absolutely not wow yeah
Team Coco for life I love Team Coco I
love Conan can you help us out a little
bit no I cannot yeah
which uh then we asked to go above his
head and they walked us back to the
management office yes uh-huh okay and by
the way your cable is still unspooling
this whole time yes 900 feet of cable
and and by the way old old women on
Walkers are tumbling left and right
you just keep hearing in the background
oh my God
clunk shatter yeah we went to the office
of the mall which was pretty cool okay
so you went into the yeah I mean this is
uh again this is if you're gonna check
out anything at the mall I think the
administrative office would be the place
this podcast opens doors yeah
so so you're in there and are you still
recording yes and then technically they
asked us to stop right we kept recording
well the old trick is to say we've we've
stopped but not stopped right and we did
do that and uh we spoke to two very nice
women and they said we can't let you
record today but here's our business
card you can email and get permission
okay which I did never heard from him oh
pinged him back heard from a new lady
she said can you please describe the
podcast I did never heard from her again
got ghosted so what we need you to do
yes and I'm glad you brought this up
yeah yeah is call out shops at Santa
Anita and say let free Sona and Matt and
Mark you know okay you know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna quote
um a really good guy
um he's a security guard at shops in
Santa Anita and say I can't help you out
come on
come on the three of us want to go back
I'm channeling the guy's Team Coco and I
gotta go with the Team Coco I can't help
you out yeah um Conan imagine if you had
the Godfather without the Godfather Part
Two we have not even been on the first
floor of this mall it's exactly the same
you're right yeah well first of all
Godfather alone I think people would
still regard as one of the greatest
movies of all as they would this episode
of the podcast yes but
if you say without the Godfather Part
Two you don't have the Godfather no you
still have the Godfather and everyone's
very happy but so that analogy doesn't
hold well they end each episode sitting
on the massage chairs and we didn't even
get to do that so I think that that
alone that's right requires us to go
back there I really need to check out
the food court too if that's important
you can't go to a mall without looking
at the food court okay
um I
you know love you guys I work with you
all the time we're team so yes I will
help you uh this is Conan O'Brien and
this message goes out to shops at Santa
Anita thank you
um I'm asking you please to let Matt
Gourley and Sona mosesian uh come back
and Mark McConnell yeah and Mark who
Mark mcconville no I'm not going to
vouch for him I don't know him that's
good he's better than me I don't know he
might be great I just don't know the guy
I can't vouch for him okay
um you have to get him in on your own
so shops at Santa Anita
um I uh I I wanted you to please please
allow uh Matt Gourley uh son of assassin
to
to um
to come and record an episode of Mall
walking it's uh walk in I'm all walking
I'm sorry you don't say the g at the end
of course got an apostrophe thank you
okay thank you Sona that's a wonderful
part of my pitch and uh we'll make all
the difference in this plea
and I just ask that you consider this
this is great promotion for shops at
Santa meeting at Shops at Santa Anita
um and uh third part of the mark
Montgomery
they're going to do a great job with
mango
can I get you saying a few different
other malls so we could just plug that
in yeah okay go ahead South Coast Plaza
hey South Coast Plaza do me a favor
Americana brand hey Americana brand
Conor O'Brien here and I need your help
Sherman Oaks Galleria hey Sherman Oaks
Galleria I know I was banned in 1988 but
please hear me out and listen to this
important message and finally The
Citadel Outlet Mall a Citadel Outlet
Mall Conan O'Brien here and uh I've got
a special request that may turn out
nicely for all of us yeah you know what
I'll say uh you should make it very
clear to these people this is
advertising
yeah did you mention that no but I
didn't I if I if I had time to mentally
prepare I would have kicked in but like
you know who's going to the mall anymore
right we're doing them a favor well okay
well first of all don't say who's going
to the mall anymore that's not going to
get you back into the shops at Santa
Anita I'm saying Dear Santa Anita like
people will listen to this podcast and
flock to the mall it's true I wrote that
in the email maybe that's why I haven't
heard back because then they knew they
couldn't take me serious sleep but well
listen I do hope I do hope you get back
in there and uh do you really I do do
you care yeah okay that's good I don't
care a lot okay I barely care Oh but I
do care no I'm thinking about it and I'm
registering
you know when the sun gets really low on
the horizon at the end of the day and
there's still just a little bit of like
a little bit of glow yeah that's how
much caring I have that's a little bit
that's fine it's still there to take it
registers yeah and um you know we'll see
and if this doesn't work maybe I gotta
show up oh you know and then
you can't just say one thing bring them
up because when people see Conan O'Brien
in a mall there's gonna be on the
floor
yeah that's you're proud of that I know
this is a selling point for
all over the mall I'm not telling
you what I want I'm telling you what
happens when I get recognized on the
street okay I have been responsible for
more public defecation than anybody in
the history of the medium I went to a
restaurant with you in Santa Anita and
it's notorious for having a long wait
and they saw you and still made us wait
45 minutes for a table you know why why
they were busy
well good luck you guys
thank you boss thank you